buenos dias angela desde lo que es sin
duda un nuevo chile el propio presidente
del gobierno sebastián piñera reconocía
anoche la desconexión de los partidos
políticos con la ciudadanía y como estos
resultados indican que es necesario que
estos partidos políticos realicen una
profunda reflexión esto es muy
importante porque el presidente es poco
dado a la autocrítica y anoche sin duda
lo hizo
vemos una composición de la convención
constituyente marcada por las fuerzas de
centroizquierda y donde también la lista
de independientes que constituye la
lista del pueblo una una lista que
tiende hacia hacia la izquierda bastante
más
extrema está presente con 24 escaños
esto obligará a las distintas fuerzas de
la convención constituyente a lograr
acuerdos veremos una convención
constituyente en la que es difícil
alcanzar acuerdo